you're going to jump in there because
ursula von de la the president of the
european commission is speaking
the proposal
hrvp
will present to you the proposal in a
few minutes
the proposal in a few minutes
at the same time we're strengthening
once more our sanctions
against the kremlin and its collaborator
lukashenka's regime
first we are shutting down the eu
airspace for russians
we're proposing a prohibition on all
russian-owned russian registered and
russian controlled aircraft
these aircraft will no more be able to
land in take off or overfly the
territory of the european union
this will apply to any plane
uncharted or otherwise controlled by a
russian legal or natural person
so let me be very clear our airspace
will be closed to every russian plane
and that includes the private jets of
oligarchs too
second
in another unprecedented step we will
ban in the european union
the kremlin's media machine
the state owned russia today and sputnik
as well as their subsidiaries
will no longer be able to spread their
lies to justify putin's war
and to saw division in our union
so we are developing tools
to ban that toxic and harmful
disinformation in europe
and third
we will target the other aggressor of
this war lukashenka's regime
lukashenko's regime is complicit in the
vicious attack
against ukraine so we will hit
lukashenka's regime with a new package
of sanctions
we will introduce restrictive measures
against their most important sectors
this will stop their exports of products
from mineral fuels to tobacco
wood and timber cement iron and steel
we will also extend to belarus the
export restrictions we introduced on
dual use goods for russia
this will also avoid any risk of
circumvention
of our measures against russia
and in addition we will sanctions those
belarusians
helping the russian war effort
all these measures come on top of the
strong package that i presented to you
last night
agreed by our international partners
under this package
important russian banks will be excluded
from the swift system
we will also ban the transactions of
russia's central bank and freeze all its
assets
to prevent it from financing putin's war
and we will target the assets of russian
oligarchs
we continue to coordinate closely with
partners around the globe
and we remain in close contact with our
ukrainian friends
president zelensky's leadership
and his bravery
and the resilience of the ukrainian
people
are outstanding and impressive
they are an inspiration for all of us
we welcome with open arms those
ukrainians who have to flee from putin's
bombs
and i'm proud of the warm welcome
that europeans have given them
we're mobilizing every effort and every
euro to support our eastern member
states
to host and take care of these refugees
we will do this in full solidarity